- I mean I'm not at all jealous
of your beautiful pregnant self.
No seriously.
- I'm trying to squeeze into this dress.
- You're pregnant.
- As I sit, thank you.
- Oh I get it
and I'm not pregnant.
But the same thing happened to me.
- Yeah, if it's not Spanx for pregnant
it's Spanx for regular
day life all the time.
- Oh my God, if I were pregnant
I would not wear Spanx,
you just own it.
- Yeah, but there's something
it's kind of comforting or something.
- I feel you though,
it kind of holds you,
you feel like your stomach's escaping.
It's like a separate thing.
- Especially this time around.
- I'm so glad you're pregnant
and not me.
- Yes!
- I can't emphasize
that enough.
- [Jenna] That's so funny.
- But you are very
pregnant so are you excited?
- Yes!
- It's your second right?
- Second.
I'm so excited.
It's been amazing.
First pregnancy was really easy.
Evie was like a dream pregnancy
and this time around
also really great but
everything's happening faster.
I'm swelling faster.
I have heartburn faster.
I was way more nauseous this time around.
So it's just like, yeah,
it's a little different.
- Maybe that means that the
opposite sex is happening.
- I know, I know.
- Yeah, maybe.
So is this
did you ever have any of the weird stuff
like either weird cravings or weird dreams
or anything like that?
- Yes.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- So many weird things.
- I only had dreams of not being pregnant.
- You were like please,
God, when is this done?
- Get out!
- When is this done?
Yeah, no, with Evie, I was super healthy.
I was actually finally,
I wanted grapefruit.
Which was like,
- [Kelly] Oh, God.
- Thank you, Evie.
- I secretly can't stand you, it's fine.
- Yeah, no, not this time, though.
This time I'm like, I want junk food.
I want everything bad.
It's really.
But it was immediate.
I was like where's the chips.
Where's Taco Bell?
I was like I needed like junk food.
- Okay, I can roll with
this kid, all right.
- [Jenna] And the dreams.
Did you have the crazy pregnant dreams?
- I literally only dreamed
of not being pregnant.
I had,
that was not an actual joke.
- Oh yeah.
No I dream really weird this pregnancy.
I had a dream the other night
that I was playing hockey
with a bunch of hockey players
and then all of a sudden
we turned into balloons
and we started floating and the problem
was we couldn't keep
our skates on the ice.
I woke up I was like, what was that?
- What does that mean?
- I need to feel grounded?
I had no idea.
- Were you pregnant while you,
- Yes.
- In the dream?
- Yes!
- Just ice skating pregnant.
- Playing hockey.
- That's another thing.
Yes I'm pregnant in the dream.
- That's what you do.
Which is really weird.
- Oh my God I missed
out on the fun dreams.
- I would've woke up trying to like
get some dream book, figure that out.
Like what's wrong with me?
- I know I just looked over,
I was like that was so weird.
I was like why am I dreaming
of hockey ever, ever?
- I'm super excited for you.
- Thank you.
- It's a very cool thing to be a mom now.
It's my favorite thing I do.